and you're willing to go to prison i am
willing to go to prison
first on the motorway now at the home
office climate activists are refusing to
be silenced
an injunction sought by the home
secretary has made intillate britain's
m25 protests illegal next time they
could be imprisoned but the group is
vowing to continue
the injunction changes nothing
the injunction changes nothing i've been
very clear this is more important my
life my children's future is more
important than a bit of paper
britain's busiest motorway has been
blocked five times in the last week by
the activists who want the government to
tackle climate change through better
home insulation
traffic's come to a standstill and each
time police have made multiple arrests
we do not think it's acceptable uh to go
and stand on the road it's bloody
dangerous
it's obviously inconvenient it's also
completely counterproductive
but the group says it's not trying to
please the public
it seems like you're targeting the
public though not the government with
your protests
we are disrupting the public we are
disrupting the system to say please this
system is killing us it's not working
for us the right to protest is clearly a
fundamental part of a democracy but the
injunction on this group shows that
right does come with conditions and
caveats particularly in the rights of
others to go about their daily lives are
affected
public disruption has become a hallmark
of climate activism ever since
extinction rebellion brought central
london to a standstill in 2019.
it wasn't a tactic deployed by
greenpeace with their flotilla on the
thames today but they seem to agree that
right now anything goes the direct
action has got a long history in this
country of people taking peaceful direct
action and we are in an emergency so i
don't know the exact details but i do
know that protesters everywhere
including us are calling on the
government to act more quickly in the
run-up to cop the closer we get to the
climate summit hosted in glasgow in just
six weeks the calls for action will
undoubtedly get more urgent and the way
they're conveyed may well get more
extreme
iva bennett sky news